Well, good morning. Again Church. It is a joy that you
chose to be with us to gather with us
to celebrate this Advent season the
Incarnation that we celebrate in a couple weeks where
Christ God himself became flesh and
dwelt Among Us 2,000 years ago.
But as you've seen the last few weeks, we're not just celebrating these
these kind of five themes of Advent.
We're all looking forward to these words that we're talking about coming in
full someday. So like they were
waiting. We are waiting also to the time when
Jesus returns for his second Advent his
second coming when he appears that
word Advent means appearing
but these five words symbolized by the five candles are
massively important.
They're really like powerful summaries of the entire main
themes of the Bible when you
think through these words of Hope and peace and joy
and love and light. That's that's really the
main themes throughout and so we've looked
at Hope and peace already and now we are today going
to study the word joy and how Jesus fulfills
the joy of every longing heart.
Will be in Luke Chapter 2 to see a glimpse of that. So take
your copy of God's word turn there with me.
Luke Chapter 2 a very traditional Christmas passage,
you'll see
but Luke Chapter 2 verses 8 through 20 is where
we will be today.
As we turn there we need to get a handle on what
Joy even is.
How can we describe Joy?
How can we Define it? So we understand what we're even talking
about when we say the word Joy. How do we describe Joy? Well,
there are many different Hebrews in the Old Testament and Greek
in the New Testament words that are translated into English
as Joy.
And so we we like the other words. We've
already studied. It has a wide swath of meaning when
you think about what Joy means.
I even used one when I got up here a few moments ago that
I said it is a joy to
have you with us.
Well what that means is that there's this feeling that
comes it Wells up inside when I see you and I
I know that you came here to worship with us and that's that's
a feeling an emotion that comes from
that that's actually one of the biblical nuances of
the word Joy talking about that feeling that
emotion of Joy where you feel
happiness.
You feel gladness. You feel joyful merriment like
Merry Christmas, like you feel these these delightful things.
It's the feeling you get when you go to a wedding.
Or when a child is born.
Or when you have this time together with your family and
or great friends at a party or when you're
you're alma mater wins the state championship like we
did last night at Fairview High School, you know, like that's that's Joy
you get from those moments you feel that
life is good you're doing well. And so
that Joy kind of Wells up inside you bubbles up. You almost
can't even control it. It just kind of flows up
the feeling you have.
Same thing can happen spiritually.
All over the book of Psalms. For example, Joy is
actually felt by Believers as they
encounter God.
God has surrounded them with his steadfast love. He's he's brought
them to Salvation. He's delivered them from his enemies. He's
given them his word. And so the the
emotion of Joy just Wells up in their lives.
It's what was felt in the parable when the shepherd found
his lost sheep.
Was much rejoicing when people saw someone be healed
by Jesus there was much rejoicing when when
adult Gentiles found out they didn't have to be circumcised. There
was much rejoicing among the people.
And listen those those are not wrong emotions to feel.
We should not feel guilty about feeling
joyful receiving Joy from
the good things. God has given us and created for
us to enjoy.
We shouldn't feel guilty about this God himself is
said to rejoice in his works and in
his people.
One of the most famous passages Luke 15 where there's the three parables
in a row about finding something that was lost. There is
said to be joy in heaven God
throws a party when someone repents and believes.
Zephaniah 3:17 is a well known verse that
describes how God views his people.
It says the Lord your God is in your midst a mighty one who will save he
will rejoice over you with gladness.
He will quiet you by his love. He will exalt over
you with loud singing.
Sounds like a party doesn't it sounds like Joy
sounds like happiness even back in Genesis 1:31 at
the very beginning. God saw everything that he had made
and behold. It was very good.
See, that's why you and I find joy in
the beautiful and good things of life.
Because God created us to do
that.
Like when that child snuggles up on your lap.
When you taste that pineapple at the resort on your honeymoon, like
maybe it's just something about that, but it was so good.
When you hear the birds chirping in the morning.
When you get that Adrenaline Rush after a good workout, when you you see
the Delight on someone's face, when you give generously to them
when you when you hug your grandpa at Christmas like those things
you feel that's right and good.
We should find joy in those things because we're made
in God's image.
And if he finds joy in good things
like that, then we ought to as well.
In fact First Timothy 6 verse 17
gives us license to be. Joyful.
It says As for the rich in this present age charges them
not to be prideful nor to set their hopes on
the uncertainty of riches but to set their hopes on God
who check this out richly provides us
with everything to enjoy.
Now I've done this with the word encourage before like encourage means
to give courage to someone enjoying something
means it gives you Joy.
God's given us things to give us
joy.
See, I think we get the wrong picture of God. He's not a cosmic
killjoy up there. Just going after you making you sad.
He's actually for your joy. He's
after your joy he wants it for you.
CS Lewis said that Joy is the serious business
of Heaven.
This is God's deal.
But God's word is also very clear.
That Joy is more than merely a Feeling.
It's more than just an emotion.
Because what happens when things aren't good.
When you don't win the game.
What happens when the holidays?
are hard
what happens when you feel alone?
What happens when like in our story?
When your wife gets pregnant immediately after having your
first son and has a miscarriage at
12 weeks.
Like if Joy is a Feeling.
Then we're sunk.
Because it's tears. That's all it is.
There's no feeling.
So Joy has to be something more. That's why the true biblical concept
of joy is more than just happiness. It goes deeper
it lasts.
Because it's based on something more solid than your circumstance.
So as we describe joy, we must also point out the times that
it is more of an action than it
is a Feeling.
Joy is actually at times commanded.
That you are to choose Joy.
No matter what you face in your life.
But that's one reason God's word is so helpful because you read
through God's word.
And you see that the Bible is not just this Joy Fest
where everything is easy and fun.
Right. This thing is hard. They face a lot of hard things right
people throughout the Bible face death. They face lost.
They face persecution. They face selfishness family
Strife all over the place, right? They
faced all of it.
Yet even in those situations.
They and we are commanded to
rejoice.
Just listen to what Jesus said.
Regarding persecution Matthew 5
verses 11 and 12 blessed are
you when others revile you and persecute you
and utter all kinds of evil against you falsely on my
account.
rejoice and be glad
for your reward is great in heaven.
For so they persecuted the prophets who were before you.
The Apostle Paul commanded it in Philippians
4:4. He says rejoice in the lord always again.
I'll say rejoice.
He doesn't say rejoice in the Lord when things are good
rejoice in Lord, most of the time rejoice in
the lord always and he repeats it for emphasis Rejoice
at all times. Even when
you face trials James one two says
Says you were to count it all joy when You Face trials
because the testing of your faith is what's going to produce steadfastness and
character in your life. Count that Joy.
Not a feeling results.
How do we get there?
How do we get to that? How do we have joy?
in the midst of struggle
in the midst of a world that's gone crazy.
In light of our own sin, how do we have joy in
this? How can we find? How can we choose Joy
here?
We'll get to it in a second.
Kind of the deep theological. Let me give you a couple simple easy ways
that you can walk this way to
find Joy first. It's getting into God's word.
When you're in the dark the hard places Psalm
16:11 shows us in his presence. There
is fullness of joy.
At his right hand are Pleasures forevermore. So God's word
is where we first can find Joy but also John
16:24. Jesus said until now you've
asked nothing in my name ask pray, and
you'll receive that your joy may be full.
So two simple ways God's word
in prayer getting into his presence just being with him fullness of
joy.
But here's how we can be assured of Joy even in struggle.
Even when it's hard, even when you lose a loved one, whatever it
is because of what Luke 2 teaches us.
This is how we can have joy.
Because what the Old Testament states were waiting for.
Everybody before Luke 2 all the way back to the beginning what
they were longing for what they were waiting for was eternal
Joy.
Because they could have joy and we'll talk about in a second. They can have joy
here and there and fits it pieces all that but but they're
all longing for this eternal Joy. It's what Isaiah prophesied
700 years for Jesus came, Isaiah 51:11.
He's looking forward to the day The
Ransom of the Lord shall return come to Zion
with singing Everlasting Joy shall
be upon their heads.
They shall obtain gladness and joy.
And sorrow and sighing shall flee
away.
See what they were longing for.
They're longing for joy.
For this deep rooted abiding Joy because
remember they've been exiled out of the Promised Land.
Because of their sin they'd experienced Carnage
and loss.
Even a couple hundred years later, they returned to the promised
land, but it wasn't the same.
And they're looking around and they're like God we we see we're
here again, but this is not it right.
And they knew they remembered that God over and
over had promised a redeemer.
Promised that someone would come to bring
that Joy again that someday they
would welcome that Joy again.
They knew it was coming. God had promised it someday, they'd
welcome Joy the fullness of joy would enter in.
Well, that's what we finally see the arrival of in Luke Chapter
2.
The fullness of joy has arrived Luke
2 verses 8 through 20. You'll recognize this as a
Christmas Passage.
In the same region there were shepherds out in
the field.
Keeping watch over their flock by night.
And an angel of the Lord appeared to them and the glory of the Lord Shone around
them and they were filled with great fear and the
angel said to them fear not.
For behold I bring you good news of great.
Joy
That will be for all the people.
For unto you is Born This Day in the city of David a
savior who's Christ the lord
And this will be a sign for you. You'll find a baby wrapped in swaddling cloths
lying in a Manger.
And suddenly there was with the angel a multitude of
the Heavenly Host praising God saying glory to God in the
highest on Earth. Peace among those with whom he's pleased.
When the angels went away from them into heaven the shepherd said to one
another let's go over to Bethlehem and see this thing that's happened, which the
Lord has made known to us.
And they went with haste and found Mary and Joseph and the
baby lying in a Manger.
And when they saw it, they made known the saying they'd been told them concerning this
child and all who heard it wondered at what the Shepherds told them. But
Mary treasured up all these things pondering them
in our heart.
And the Shepherds returned out to their field glorifying
and praising God for all
they had heard and seen as it had been told them.
So we see this this baby born
who who is declared to be all of
these things, right? You see it the son of David that's the prophecy fulfilled
of who he was going to be born in Bethlehem, Micah
5. We saw that a couple weeks ago. That was fulfilled.
The Savior the Lord the the promised Messiah was
coming and finally.
here
But instead of being afraid of that reality the angel
said to the Shepherds guys, you don't need to be afraid
of this because he's not coming with the sword yet.
He's not coming to judge yet.
He's actually bringing Joy.
They brought good news.
To these with these Shepherds that were cast off
from sighted about great news of great. Joy to
them that the Messiah had come.
Don't be afraid.
Because what's been promised for Generations, you're finally seeing.
He's come. He's shown up. Look, he's here this baby that
would forgive sins and guide his people into peace. He's here.
This is the one you've been waiting for. This was the promise fulfilled.
The Messiah is here.
No wonder the Shepherds were Overjoyed as they
went back home. Did you see what they were doing? Right they were full
of joy. They were glorifying and praising God
for what they had just heard and seen.
They finally had seen that longing in
their hearts. Remember what they were longing for for Generation. They
finally saw it fulfilled.
the joy of their longing heart
because remember before that.
There was only partial Joy.
There was there was mere glimpses of God's
Deliverance throughout Israel's history.
Now those moments did bring joy.
Those those moments did did bring Joys
I remembered back to how God had delivered them. Especially out
of Egypt.
numbers 10 10 commands them to Mark those
moments with with times of rejoicing it
says
like guys remember
You're my people you need to remember. That's what the whole
thing about the Passover the feast the Feast of
unleavened bread the Pentecost celebration the Feast
of Tabernacles that was all for the idea
to remind them that they were once slaves
and God delivered them.
remember
Don't forget Rejoice over the fact that you not
in Egypt anymore.
You're here.
And in those festivals you go read through all of them. They are commanded
to rejoice.
They didn't have an option. They were commanded to Rejoice
because of what God had done because he had helped them before they
say here's what you do in this
celebration.
but again
Even as they celebrated those things.
Even as they look back and saw Egypt, they saw the Red Sea split.
There was still an element of longing in those
celebrations.
It was still only partial Joy.
Because think about where they were celebrating that party.
They're in the middle of the desert.
They're vulnerable.
The promised land is still miles away somewhere way over there.
We don't know where it is.
And then later they're in Exile. They're commanded
to celebrate these Feast under the authority
of the Babylonian Empire.
They're away from the land still under
oppression. And God says yes celebrate. Don't
forget remember.
And so yes, they were commanded to rejoice in God's
past Deliverance.
But they were still longing until Luke 2 happens. They were
still longing for full Joy.
for full restoration
But think about that is that not similar for us today?
See we can look back at Luke 2 and see that this Christ
child in Bethlehem called the Lord and the Savior.
We know that he came and did accomplish
the work.
Because he didn't stay a baby right like Christmas is part of
it, but then you've got Easter come you've got the whole story right?
There's more to the story than just Jesus in a manger.
Because he grew up and he lived the perfect life that you and I
could never live.
And then he died the death that we deserve to
defeat the enemy that was keeping us enslaved to
our sin.
And then he rose again from Death to
defeat that enemy that there's no way we could
defeat on our own like this is what he was doing. Praise the
lord we can look back and say he did it.
This good news about Jesus here. This this should
give us great joy too as we look back to our deliverance. This
should give us in a spark in us a
desire to Rejoice the ability to Rejoice
because just like for them with Exodus their
greatest enemy Was Defeated our greatest enemy
is defeated our sin in Jesus life
death and Resurrection.
So Rejoice, right?
So we should have joy and it
should also not just for you on your own. It should
ignite in us together a great celebration Every
Time We Gather just like the feast
in the Old Testament.
At Passover they would gather together and they
would celebrate together and with joy they would
remember.
It's the same for us as we remember what God has
done as we gather together. In fact, Joy is
part of one of our churches values.
Life Giving hope
where we reflect the Gospel of
Jesus Christ with delight.
by building relationships and environments infused
with Grace and with joy
in other words
you and I need what we call gospel-centered Community.
to enjoy
remember we need people.
To help give us joy.
And every time we gather as a
church like this, these should be life-giving.
These should be joy infusing to
us that we walk out of here not remembering me
or anyone else up here, but we remember how great our
God is and we walk out here with a little more. Joy, right?
That's what this is supposed to be.
But here's what else that means.
If you sit there week by week.
unmoved
by the grace of Jesus
if you can look at this gospel.
And not be stirred in your heart over what
Jesus has done for you?
Unless you should be concerned about that.
You should be worried about the state
of your heart and your soul.
Now I get it. Listen, I get it that there's Dark Knights
of the soul in our lives where where it's a
fight to lift your eyes to Jesus. Absolutely that happens.
I've been there and so let me just talk to you keep stepping
forward in faith, like keep battling. Keep going
towards him every day lift your eyes lift your
eyes. Yes.
But if you weak by week by
week by month by year are completely
indifferent.
To how sinful you really are.
Or to how gracious God really is to give
you salvation.
Then you need to repent and believe.
Like joy joy is a natural byproduct of
salvation.
It's part of the deal because just think about well, we were
still sinners Christ died for us. Well, we
were still sinners Christ made us as children. He adopted
us into his family and said I want you in my family. I'm gonna
pay for my you're with with my son's life. I'm gonna
pay for you to be in here with me. What great love
is this
Like what great joy, that should
create in us, right?
Because listen whether things are good or things are bad in your
life when you believe that Jesus is Love
overcame death itself.
Then Joy becomes reasonable.
and even the darkest of circumstances
even death cannot overcome him.
So whatever I'm facing today can't be
worse than that. And so it gives me joy.
Listen, it's possible friend.
Even if you don't feel it right now.
Joy is possible because it's not found in circumstances. It's
found in him.
That's the whole point of this is that Jesus gives Joy, but
here's again, I know.
Similar to Israel of old. The reality is
that we are also still waiting for something to
the fact that I had to even talk about the Dark Night of the soul and those kind
of things like that's the reality is that we're still getting knocked down
every day.
We have an enemy trying to steal our joy every
day continually trying to take it away from
us. We have this reality John 10:10. Jesus said
it's here. The enemy comes to steal kill and
destroy.
We're still in the middle of this some of you feel it.
But remember Jesus didn't stop there. He said that I came that
they may have life and have it abundantly.
So again, you can have that Abundant Life. Now
you can have this Joy Now by welcoming Jesus
so that his Joy can
be in you and your joy may be full John
15 says
he's not talking about only after you die.
He's talking about even now.
It's just that we're gonna have to look for him.
And for that satisfying Joy through a bit of a mess.
right now
I read this powerful illustration from Paul Thigpen. He's
writing this from his his first person perspective. Listen to
this. He says I remember coming home one afternoon to discover
that the kitchen. I had worked so hard to clean only a
few hours before was now a terrible wreck.
My young daughter had obviously been busy cooking.
And the ingredients were scattered along with dirty bowls utensils across
the counters and the floor. I was not happy with
the situation.
But then as I looked a little more closely at the mess, I spied a
tiny little note on the table.
clumsily written and smeared with chocolatey fingerprints
and the message was short.
I'm making something for you Dad.
And it was signed your angel.
And so in the midst of that disarray and despite my irritation Joy
suddenly sprang up in
my heart.
sweet and pure
my attention had been redirected from the problem to the
little girl that I loved.
And as I encountered her in that brief note I delighted
in her.
with her single simple goodness in focus
I could take pleasure in seeing her hand at work in
a situation that seemed otherwise disastrous.
The church the same is true of our joy in the Lord.
Galatians 5:22 says one of the fruits of the spirit of
God living inside you is joy.
Which means we can look through
the mess and we can welcome joy
as we see God making something
for us in the middle of all of it. No matter
what we face.
Now I'm not saying we pretend that our problems don't exist or hardship
doesn't exist. We just know that true Joy transcends
our suffering because we
know suffering will not have the final word.
It's what Paul said in sync Corinthians 6:10. He said we can
be sorrowful yet always rejoicing you can
have both at the same time. It's a miracle of
God's grace that we can still have joy in it now
now listen you might have to fight hard for the joy.
You might have to look hard for it. You might have to cling to
him for it.
But you're not the first.
To have to do that.
It's the same at habakkuk face and
chapter 3
says though the Fig Tree should not blossom.
Nor fruit beyond the vines the produce of
the olive fail the fields yield no food.
The flock be cut off from the fold and they're
being no herd in the Stalls. Basically no income. No.
Hope of income nothing to eat.
Yet.
I will rejoice in the Lord.
I will take joy in the god of
my salvation.
It's there for you.
Yet again.
Even in that.
There's still an element of longing, right?
Because we're still looking through the mess.
Even though I could have joy even want
to facing nothing. I got nothing I got no. Hope of anything I can
still have joy, but they're still looking through the
mess. Our bodies are still broken. The enemy still rages
against us family still struggle. It's still here
and we can have abundant Joy
now, but we also like they did we look
forward to the day when we can welcome that
full joy that Everlasting joy that
was promised back in Isaiah 51.
Like we can look to that day when we enter into it's one
of the Parables Jesus gives we enter into the joy
of our master.
It's the very presence of God.
face to face
It's what the end of Revelation describes.
That not only will there be perfect. Peace.
No more sin. No More Death no more pain.
There's going to be full Joy someday as well.
where those
Those feasts in the Old Testament what they were symbolizing what
they were giving tastes of is we throw a party for
what God's done. Remember what he did in the past over. We're having a
great time looking forward to something coming all that
in. The Book of Revelation is finally completed. It's finally
brought back together where we celebrate not only
by looking back to what he's done, but also
looking face to face at our God himself.
That's what the Apostle John saw in heaven. We looked there Revelation 19:6
and 70 says I heard what seem to be
the voice of a great multitude like the Roar of many Waters the
sound of many peels of Thunder crying out Hallelujah. Like
we sang earlier for the Lord Our God the
Almighty Reigns, let us rejoice let
us exult and give him the glory for
the marriage of the Lamb has come the bride has
made herself ready.
So here's what this is doing. This is previewing what's called The Wedding Feast
someday where this this group
of people the Believers that are in him
that's us Christians called the bride of
Christ. We come to this party. We're finally finished
being prepared and the groom himself enters
into the party and forever. We will
together worship and joy and
gladness and celebration for all that. He
is all that he's done and all that. He has given us
praise God. We look forward to that day. Don't
we
and we say like the end of revelation 22 come quickly Lord
Jesus.
Because we want full Joy.
But also listen to this.
Because we are so Overjoyed by that gospel message
and by that future that is coming for
us. Listen. We should not hoard that Joy.
This should not merely be for
us. Remember what the angel told the Shepherds that
night?
Luke 2:10
Look at it again. He says.
Fear not for behold I bring you good news
of great joy.
That will be for all the people.
see that
this good news of great joy is for all the
people.
All the peoples meaning this is a global gospel
the truth that Jesus himself repeated
throughout his ministry Matthew 5:14. You're
the light of the world a city on a hill
cannot be hidden Matthew 24:14. This Gospel of the Kingdom
will be proclaimed throughout the whole world as a
testimony to All Nations Matthew 28:19 go and
make disciples of all Nations Acts 1:8, you'll
be my Witnesses Jerusalem Judea Samaria to the end of
the Earth So Hear Me Church Advent must not
be a time that we just get together and celebrate internally. We
have a great time remembering what God's done
in the past what he's going to do in the future rejoicing over that
No, this must Propel us outward to where
we Proclaim joy as we have received
it as we've welcomed it. We Proclaim it
to all the people that there is good news of great joy,
that is calm and this Joy is found.
in him
that Joy we're talking about.
Should be fuel for the mission.
Like why are we going to go? Why would we ever sacrifice
to what we have here the Comforts and
go somewhere else move to the other side of the world Goss the
street and share like, why would we do that and and make things hard for
ourselves without the Joy on the other side?
That's what Jesus did.
Hebrews 12:2 for the joy set before
him endured the cross
He knew it was there. He saw the other side. He
saw the results not feeling good going to the Cross but
he saw the result of what it was going to bring and so for the joy set
before him. He endured that cross. So we
who have received his joy and we have
overwhelmingly Been Changed by his
joy. We must go Proclaim that Joy
that we have it.
No matter what. We're facing in our life.
No matter what. We're facing circumstantially that we have it you better
in our lives. We better Proclaim Joy just simply by
living a life. That looks different.
When you lose a loved one when you face trials financially that
your life is full of joy from the
Lord as your strength.
We Proclaim Joy just by being that kind of
Lifestyle, but also that that Joy is
available to a weary world around
us.
To those who are hurting to those who are dark This Joy
is available because listen if the Lord God
Almighty has kindled a fire in the
dead cold fireplace of your heart.
What else can you do but respond by by joyfully
living in response to that and
joyfully going in response to that.
There's no better way to respond.
By living and proclaiming joy to all
the people.
And so that candle of joy is what we're going to light this morning.
As we both look back and look ahead this third candle
of the Advent wreath. We've talked about hope
We've talked about peace and now we add the
element of joy.
That Christ has come to bring in Christ will fully
bring one day.
I don't invite the Crawford Family up here to lead us through
that today Marcus is one of our deacons and they co-lead a
community group together in both markets and Kristen serve
Faithfully in many ways and our kids ministry.
And their family's going to light the candle read some scripture pointing us to the
Messiah and then pray for our joy together.
Of the increase of his government and of Peace, there will be
no end on the throne of David and over his kingdom to establish
it and to uphold it with Justice and with
righteousness from the time forth and forevermore.
The Zeal of the Lord of hosts will do this. The Lord
has sent word against Jacob and it
will fall on Israel.
And all the people will know Ephraim and the evidence
of Samaria who say in Pride in an arrogance
of heart. The bricks have fallen, but we will build with
dress Stones the sycamores have been got town, but we'll
put cedars in their place.
Would you pray with me Church?
Father we are thankful for for the prophets
of old for the prophets like Isaiah that foretold of
the coming of Jesus father. I can't imagine the
anticipation that the people had father for
us on this side of that. We see it to
be absolute truth.
And God, we we praise your
name for for sending Jesus.
as Our Redeemer father as as our
joy May that his birth and
and the way that he lived a perfect life died for us
father made that
fuel us.
To share the joy that we have for the world father.
God send us as a church to do just that to
proclaim the name of Jesus as Our Redeemer. Amen.